it can be tough for a movie studio to
know when they've got a flop on their
hands until it's too late but once in a
while films come along that have
disaster written all over them in big
flashing neon letters long before
they're released the writing was on the
wall for these pictures well before they
made their way to theaters they're some
of the biggest box-office bombs of all
time and many of us saw them coming from
a mile away
Aeon Flux the live-action adaptation of
MTV's animated series Aeon Flux with
Charlize Theron in the title role
arrived a full decade after the last
episode of the show aired already facing
that uphill battle the film was shuffled
around through multiple regime changes
at Paramount studio head Sherry Lansing
initially told director Karyn Kusama
that she wanted it to be paramount
answer to Blade Runner but incoming
chief Gail Berman wanted more of a Buffy
the Vampire Slayer vibe after struggling
through the shoot with unclear
directives Kusama then endured the
ultimate insult as a third incoming
administration removed her from the
post-production process and in her words
eviscerated the film no when I reflect
back on it I'm like what was a thinking
about 25 minutes was sliced from
kazama's cut resulting in a barely
coherent movie who sama would later say
what they didn't realize is that
sometimes a cohesive 100 minutes will
feel much shorter than an incoherent and
barely comprehensible 82 it predictably
garnered appalling reviews and barely
registered at the box office
Cowboys and Aliens Cowboys and Aliens
seemed like the kind of high concept
romp that the right filmmaker could
knock out of the park and director Jon
Favreau fresh off the success of a Iron
Man and its sequel certainly seemed like
the man for the job with Steven
Spielberg as a producer in an all-star
cast including Daniel Craig and Harrison
Ford big things were in store for the
picture but they missed a couple of red
flags the script was labored over by
more than a dozen writers for 14 years
which is never a good sign it also
tracked poorly with its target audience
for the duration of its long marketing
campaign the biggest insult of all it
just barely managed to edge out the
Smurfs in its opening week I'm so sorry
I didn't realize a sad for you it
ultimately failed to make back its
production budget domestic
Cowboys and Aliens certainly had a
wealth of talent but everyone involved
forgot the crucial step of making sure
they were crafting a picture people
actually wanted to see Fantastic Four
production problems are a pretty
reliable indicator that a big-budget
tentpole film could be in trouble and
few have had production issues as
extensive as 2015's Fantastic Four from
questionable casting to clashes between
director Josh Trank and writer producer
Simon Kinberg rumors flew fast and
furious about the snafus plaguing
Fantastic Four four months before the
film's release tranq and Kinberg
publicly shot down these rumors but then
the film hit theaters and it became
astoundingly clear that every single
rumor had been true and then some
audiences stayed away and those who gave
it a chance mostly wished they had in
the wake of the hostile reviews Trank
defended his work via twitter by
implying that the studio had savaged the
film in editing
as for Kinberg he ignored the film's
troubled production history by placing
the blame for its failure on its tone
proving that some people fail to learn
lessons even when they're taught the
hard way JOHN CARTER Disney's John
Carter had a lot of things going for it
it was the start of an adaptation of a
series of classic influential sci-fi
novels by Edgar Rice Burroughs and
director Andrew Stanton had previous
hits with Pixar including wall-e and
Finding Nemo and it had the massive
production budget one would expect for a
tentpole film any or all of these things
would have been brilliant to play up in
the film's marketing so of course the
first trailer capitalized by mentioning
exactly none of them
the teaser appeared in July 2011 and it
wasn't until the 2012 Super Bowl that a
second trailer was released
unfortunately it wasn't much better
speaking with vulture an anonymous
former studio executive called John
Carter's marketing campaign the worst in
history saying it's almost as if they
went out of their way to not make us
care amazingly the problem was
compounded by Stan's complete loyalty to
the source material assuming that the
public at large would adore John Carter
as much as he did
irony but you are beautiful and you
fight like a fire this colossal
miscalculation plus the vague marketing
campaign equaled very few butts in the
seats and Carter became far and away the
biggest flop of 2012
The Lone Ranger when Disney's
live-action The Lone Ranger was
announced in 2010 it wasn't clear
whether audiences were up for a
retelling of The Adventures of the
Western hero plus a few feathers were
ruffled over the choices of army hammer
and the title role and the decidedly non
made of Johnny Depp as his Native
American sidekick Tonto the production
was briefly shut down over budget
concerns in 2011 but managed to get back
on track then in early 2012 fans were
treated to the first glimpse of the film
featuring Hammer and the famous mask and
Depp in the most egregiously terrible
Tonto makeup anyone could have imagined
the images quickly drew jeers giving
observers plenty of negative things to
talk about before the film was finally
released in July 2013 it failed to
generate any significant positive social
media buzz and analysts correctly
predicted that the film would be
trounced by Despicable Me 2 which opened
the same weekend and went on to gross
nearly a billion dollars
[Music]